Someone left a message asking if we
could separate out the Claude code
skills into their own videos. So, today
we're launching a brand new series,
GitHub trending skills, episode 1.
35 open source repositories.
Let's get started.
You ask an AI a simple question and get
certainly, I'd be happy to explain,
followed by five paragraphs of robotic
fluff. Talk normal is a system prompt
that fixes that. Drop it into Claude,
ChatGPT, or your local LLM and it strips
away the AI slop. No filler, no
restating the question, no robotic
transitions. Just direct, concise,
structurally sound answers.
Minimax AI skills is an official skills
kit that turns Claude code into senior
engineers.
Strict production grade workflows force
the AI through requirements analysis,
architecture design, then
implementation. Expert skill packs for
full stack React, Android, iOS, and even
complex GLSL shaders.
Ask your agent in the IDE to write and
sing a personalized song or convert a
photo into an animated Funko Pop sticker
using their generation APIs.
Ever looked at Stripe or Apple and
wished you could steal their entire
design system? NPX skill we reverse
engineers design systems from any URL,
GitHub repo, or local project with one
command. No AI involved, no API keys
required. Pure static analysis. Default
mode extracts design tokens, fonts, and
hex colors. Ultra mode fires up headless
Playwright to capture scroll journeys,
hover interactions, and complex CSS
animations.
Email campaigns-Claude
is an autonomous email agent that
connects Claude code directly to the
Resend API. Give it a prompt like,
"Draft a three-part welcome sequence for
new users." And Claude writes the copy,
codes the HTML layouts, optimizes
subject lines, and dispatches the bulk
emails via Resend. Your terminal becomes
a full-time marketing manager. No SaaS
menus, no subscription fees.
Harness is a meta skill that builds the
entire AI team for you. Type, "Build a
harness for this project." and it
analyzes your domain, picks from six
architectures like producer reviewer or
hierarchical delegation, then generates
all the specialized agent definitions
and custom skills needed for them to
collaborate.
Handles inter-agent data passing, error
handling, and orchestration
automatically.
Your AI writes the code, you ship the
feature, you learn absolutely nothing.
Anti-Vibe is a Claude code skill that
fixes that. After every coding session,
automatic hooks trigger a specialized
sub-agent that generates a deep dive
markdown file explaining why the AI
wrote the code that way, what CS
patterns are in play, and curated
resources to learn more. Runs in the
background with zero friction, works
with any language.
Auto skills is a CLI that installs your
entire AI skill stack with one command.
Run NPX auto skills in your project root
and it scans your package.json and
config files to detect your exact tech
stack. Next.js, Tailwind, Spring Boot,
whatever you're using.
Automatically pulls the best community
curated markdown skills from the
skills.sh registry straight into your
project.
AI image generators give you messy
bitmaps with weird text. You wanted a
logo, you got a mess.
Logo generator skill uses Claude code to
write the raw SVG code for your logo.
Tell it your project name and industry.
Get six geometric vector-based design
variations. Pure SVG means infinitely
scalable, fully responsive, and you can
drag it straight into Figma to tweak
radii, gradients, and layout.
Claude code generates UIs that look sort
of like Material Design, but ignore the
actual strict guidelines.
Material 3 skill turns your AI into a
certified Google Material Design 3
expert.
30+ components, the full dynamic tonal
color system, and responsive layout
breakpoints. Feed it one seed color and
get a perfectly balanced light and dark
mode theme.
Litch skills injects a strict
spec-driven development workflow into
your agent, forcing it to plan and
design architecture before writing a
single line of code. Beyond that, it
equips your AI with live web search via
the Tavily API to look up latest
documentation and hooks into Nano Banana
for instant image generation right from
your terminal.
3GP skill turns Claude into a senior
telecom consultant grounded in actual
engineering standards from 2G through 6G
and release 21. Ask complex questions
like how 5G protects against IMSI
catchers or how to migrate from LTE to
5G core and it maps the entire protocol
flow across the PPHY, MAC, and RRC
layers. Every single answer backed by
exact technical specification
references. No hallucinations.
AI writing sounds like AI writing.
Inside Lago-Voice skill fixes that. The
founder of Lago had multiple viral
Hacker News hits and just open sourced
the exact Claude skill she used to write
them. A framework for teaching an AI to
write like you, not a corporate version
of you.
Seven structured sections including
voice, core rules, and an anti-filler
checklist. You feed it your personal
anti-patterns, the exact manual edits
you always make to fix AI drafts.
Marp slides is a Claude code skill that
turns your agent into a master
presentation designer.
It uses 22 curated reference decks to
teach Claude how to compose beautiful
Marp decks using pure markdown and raw
HTML. Prompt it with, "Create a dark
mode presentation reviewing my Q1 sales
data." and it autonomously builds the
entire deck with SVG bar charts, metric
cards, and polished layouts.
Managing a swarm of AI agents means when
one tool breaks, every agent on your
team fails the same way until you
manually rewrite the code. Skill claw
fixes that with collective skill
evolution. A local proxy silently
monitors your agents. When one discovers
a new workflow or hits an error, an
autonomous agentic evolver analyzes the
session, dynamically rewrites the tool's
logic, and syncs the upgrade to a shared
cloud repository.
SVG hand-drawn skill plugs into Claude
code or cursor. Feed it a rigid
corporate SVG chart, logo, or icon and
it converts it into a beautiful rough
hand-drawn style graphic. It doesn't
output a static image. It generates a
complete HTML preview with a player
script that animates the SVG making it
look like the graphic is being
physically sketched onto the screen in
real time.
Buffett skills distills Warren Buffett's
entire value investing brain into an
autonomous agent skill. Drop the
skill.md into Claude code or open claw
and it transforms your agent into a
ruthless fundamental value investor.
Give it an annual report or ticker. It
runs structured analysis on economic
moat, management integrity, intrinsic
value, and long-term capital allocation.
Paper orchestra transforms your single
AI assistant into a full academic
ensemble.
Outline agent, plotting agent,
literature review agent, and content
refiner. Feed it your messy pre-writing
notes and the swarm synthesizes a deep
literature review, generates conceptual
diagrams, iteratively refines clarity
through simulated peer review, and
outputs a perfectly formatted LaTeX
file.
Staring at a massive undocumented legacy
codebase is one of the worst feelings in
software. How is a cursor plugin that
adds a  how command to your
workspace? Ask, "How does the message
virtualization work?" and instead of a
raw code snippet, you get a structured
architectural explanation like a senior
staff engineer onboarding you to the
team.
Running a Shopify store means clicking
through hundreds of admin pages or
paying for expensive third-party apps.
Shopify admin-skills is a collection of
63 AI agent skills built specifically
for operating Shopify stores.
Install it with NPX skills add,
authenticate with the Shopify CLI, and
your local AI agent becomes an
e-commerce manager.
AI life skills is a collection of
markdown skill files that transform
Claude code into a proactive life coach.
Analyzes your daily journal entries to
detect burnout, reviews your calendar to
aggressively schedule deep work blocks,
automates daily reflection logs. Catch
yourself infinite scrolling on Twitter
during a focus block and it literally
shuts down the browser tab via OS
command and forces you to type a
reflection on why you broke focus.
Paper finder is a Claude code skill
explicitly tuned for deep ML literature
research.
Drop it in your workspace and your AI
agent acts like a senior PhD advisor
instead of a dumb search bar. The
creator tested it on bleeding edge
topics like mixed resolution diffusion
and efficient video tokenization. It
consistently unearths hidden gem papers
that traditional search engines
completely miss.
Engineering figure banana is a Claude
code skill with a dual mode architecture
that separates conceptual diagrams from
quantitative plots.
System architecture or algorithm
workflow goes through an image model.
Benchmark chart or scatter plot where
the numbers actually matter forces plot
mode and writes exact code to render the
geometry locally.
Cursor just introduced agent skills, but
figuring out how to write good ones
takes trial and error.
Awesome-Cursor-Skills
is a curated collection of ready-to-use
skills you paste directly into your
cursor  skills
directory. Suggesting cursor rules,
watches your corrections, and if you
keep fixing the same styling mistake,
autonomously proposes a permanent rule.
Skill-based architecture is a meta skill
designed to organize your other skills.
Feed it your long single-file prompts or
scattered project rules, and it
autonomously refactors them into a
structured skills directory tree.
Monolithic instructions get broken into
modular purpose-built files. Your agent
only reads the exact content it needs,
exactly when it needs it.
Making an Apple Keynote-style promo
video usually takes days in After
Effects and 3D software. C dance skill
automates it entirely.
This Claude code skill integrates
ByteDance's C dance 2.0 motion graphics
model straight into your terminal via
the Foul AI API. Point your agent at an
App Store link or a folder of
screenshots. It uses specialized liquid
glass prompting to autonomously generate
a glossy cinematic promo clip.
Friday is a fully autonomous 24/7 AI
assistant built using nothing but Claude
code CLI and a single markdown file. The
entire brain lives in that file, backed
by a tiny Flask server for persistent
rag memory. It sends morning weather and
crypto briefings via Telegram, monitors
Hugging Face for new models, pushes Git
commits, transcribes YouTube videos, and
creates self-healing cron jobs.
Agentic SEO from Adi Ozmani is Google
Lighthouse, but specifically for AI
agent readiness. Run it against your
site or docs, and it scans for
machine-readable signals like llms.texty
files, clean markdown, and strict token
limits.
Make sure your API references don't blow
out an agent's context window. Checks
whether you have skill.md or agents.md
files exposed, so bots know how to
navigate your code base.
PowerPoint and Google Slides are
tedious. HTML PPT skill automates
presentations entirely. An installable
Claude code skill that turns your agent
into a professional presentation
designer. Feed it a rough outline or
markdown, it outputs a single
self-contained HTML slide deck. 24
themes, 31 layouts, 20-plus built-in
animations. Everything bundled with
inline CSS and JavaScript, runs
perfectly in any browser.
AI agents burn tokens writing polite
essays just to give you one line of
code.
Caveman Claude skill is an
ultra-compressed communication mode that
forces your AI to talk like a literal
caveman. Drops articles, filler, and
hedging while preserving 100% of the
technical accuracy and code blocks. Cuts
output token usage by up to 75%
Adjustable intensity levels including a
classical Chinese mode for extreme
character compression.
Keeping system prompts and project rules
in sync across Claude code, cursor, and
codex is painful. Manual SDD is a
skills-first starter kit you drop into
your repo that introduces spec-driven
development for the AI era. Instead of
configuring each tool separately, you
maintain a single canonical AI specs
folder. Clever symlinks make your
.cursor, .claude, and .codex directories
all read from the exact same centralized
playbook.
Hue is an installable Claude code skill
that learns any brand from a URL,
company name, or screenshot, and
instantly reverse engineers it into a
complete reusable design system. Color
tokens, typography scales, plus strict
recipes for light and dark modes. Run
the install command and drop it into
your .claude/skills folder.
Every interface your AI builds from that
moment is strictly bound to that custom
design language.
Jetpack Compose audit skill is like
having a senior Android architect review
your code base. It doesn't just use
generic LLM prompts. It runs a built-in
Gradle script to generate and parse your
raw compose compiler metrics.
Combines that hard deterministic
compiler data with AI reasoning to give
your project a brutal quantified audit
score out of 100.
My AI workflow is Matteo Barbaro's
battle-tested methodology open-sourced.
Instead of diving straight into prompts,
a custom skill forces the AI to
interview you first. Explore the code
base, ask hard architectural questions,
walk every branch of the design tree,
resolve dependencies, all before a
single line of code gets written. The
output is a structured PRD that becomes
the source of truth for your agents
going forward.
Scraping a modern webpage with AI
usually ends in disaster. Blocked by
Cloudflare or drowning your context
window in thousands of lines of useless
HTML. Spider King skill is the drop-in
web crawler skill for AI assistants.
Handles headless browser rendering,
navigates anti-bot protections, and
strips away DOM noise automatically.
Feeds clean structured markdown or JSON
directly into your LLM's memory.
Google's official Android team dropped a
massive repository of AI skills covering
canonical best practices for XML to
Jetpack Compose migrations. But manually
reformatting raw markdown for every AI
tool is a nightmare. Android skills MCP
is an MCP server and CLI packager from
Skydoves that bridges all of it. One NPX
command translates Google's raw skills
into native rule formats for seven
different AI agents.
>> [music]